[Music]
an extremely sick cat what's up guys my
name is Carla and I am obsessed with my
rating score on uber as a passenger so
we're gonna have so much of drivers what
they find annoying so that I can make
sure to avoid those things so I can keep
that score what would you say would make
you rate somebody less than a five you
know they're drunk and they're demanding
and they just want me to do exactly what
they want to do that's probably the most
annoying thing
[Music]
do you ever get people in like that get
in your face or like touchy or like
especially when they're drunk they're
drinking and they don't know where
they're going they tell you to use Waze
while I have a google here this is
sometime in Russia was about to figure
I'm honestly fine with wet or dry food I
just like playing hard to feed what kind
of Drive echo friendly does John just be
a backseat driver being demanding I
think that's true because there's a way
to talk to people done customer there
they don't know we're going out sometime
whatever they're saying doesn't make a
sense you know just give us a tip in
this hidden shut up
yeah once they get there bad day
it was a great day why started out with
the Maine Governor giving a press
conference apologizing for really dumb
things he said that were pretty racist
and then digging the hole deeper
Beyonce keeps popping up everywhere she
is going to be in the Super Bowl
halftime show and she was also on the
Channing Tatum lip-sync battle that was
a big deal I'm so out of breath
everything so exciting manatees are on
the rebound it's true they're no longer
endangered also great jobs numbers oh I
just saw a condition right now and so
happy
[Music]